hello welcome back to dev ox 2013 we're
here right after the Google keynote with
Lars and Casper hey and welcome guys and
congratulations you've just announced
dart mandar oh sure did fantastic news
yeah I know you've been working hard on
it i'm pretty sure you spend the last
two and a half years working on that so
finally is out and it seems like is well
received so fantastic new platform for
writing web applications right so give
me the the big picture on in terms of
what it's trying to do the fact that
it's not just a language probably by the
elevator pitch the elevator pitch yes
very short first floor we only 11 / gap
the only thing you want is to make it
program was more efficient when when
they write web applications and today is
that's good that's good and some
obstacles we think the language is not
structured enough for riding big
applications liking of tools and you're
trying to solve that the dot okay and so
that is a combination of a programming
language which set of consistent
libraries an IDE and then we have the
final piece we have a chromium with dart
VM support so that means that when you
do development if you change the code
you can try it right away I think no lag
in tools when using it I think it's
worth adding that in addition to having
that that native way of running dart
code you can also compiled our 22
JavaScript and run it across today's
browsers which would be probably so
you're talking about the developer use
case which is as fast as possible of a
round trip so you get immediate feedback
on your changes and you're more
addressing the deployment story which
today probably will be more about
generating JavaScript but it so it's a
valid point you need to deploy your
application and by no means via we don't
want to to fragment the web so it's
important that when you translate that
our code into JavaScript will work on
all the modern browsers so let's drill
down just a little bit on this how how
good of a job are you actually doing
generating that JavaScript you know how
big how efficient is the code that's
being generated so the generated code is
it's getting very very good so when we
measure performance of the generated
code and the size of the track it over
time and we've made lots of good
improvements there to a point where
generated JavaScript code and emitted
from the dr. J's compiler is as
efficient as handwritten code for a lot
of cases and I probably should have
mentioned that you guys are performance
guys young you've been working on aw God
on ba then the goal every time was
really to enable new class of
applications because the speed was so
much faster so performance is good
people tend to like it it's easy that
way perfect one thing i should add about
performance is that if you if you
increase performance in a platform you
enable new classes of applications to
run on a platform and that certainly
have it happened on the web where over
the last five years a performance of the
browser has just went through the roof
right and suddenly you see very complex
and very animated applications running
on the web and it's just due to
performance when you give performance to
programmers they'll use it especially if
you give them a hundred times
performance improvement that really
changes the game like things that you
couldn't build before a pub suddenly
possible to build right so this is one
that oh and you guys are talking
performance already why not no great I
think it's a great feature of
performance is always a great feature it
tends to be a one that one or two not a
feature in this case it's not right I
mean but yes but forgot to mention the
dot VM we have we also have a vm for
that yes it's running twice as fast as
javascript as Jonas program so it's not
too bad this is good starting point and
you we expect that over the next year to
to dramatically increase the speed both
on the translated code to do sure but
also on the NATO implementation so the
end result is web applications but not
only you can go we'll probably talk
about where else you can use dart but
who is this really target of that is it
what kind of developers is it JavaScript
developers today web developers maybe
service I trying to get into there's a
lot of interest from people that
actually have a background in the Java C
sharp that they want to try to find a
good way of using their skills on on the
web for building web apps we certainly
see a lot of people interested there so
it's worth mentioning probably is the
optional typing
optional typing is interesting in that
you can you can start out to improve
typing without being bothered by the
types when you didn't get your structure
into the program you can start adding
aesthetic types in your AP is so at
least other other teams that use your
code can see how it should be used yes
documenting the intent of your code
makes a ton of sense curves you work
they also it also makes much more
readable so given that you're serious
about doing web applications your
application will survive for a long time
and you need to maintain it and refactor
and the more intent you have specified
in the program that easy it is to
maintain over time I guess a simple
description of that that is that we
found that people that use dart for
writing web apps I have an easier time
actually taking a sample and
understanding what it does and finding
relevant documentation from the type of
notations then people that start from
JavaScript because you don't have the
types in there to tell you what to look
for in the documentation so it's really
helpful yep so other than types you it
has everything you would expect from a
modern language so packages built-in
lambdas all of those things you want to
talk about maybe synthetics sugar you
feel you've mentioned it you've done a
demo and during the keynote sure I mean
that so we try not to add too much
intense and syntactic sugar but
sometimes you just want to express your
your code in a concise nice way without
repeating yourself over and over again
so and we've added a few things that
make it easier to construct objects and
in a simple insane way without repeating
the field names and the parameter name
is all over the place like it's common
in some other languages and so we've
done a lot of things to just take cut
down on the boilerplate so it's we like
to call like a ceremony free language
you don't have to write tons of code
just to get your your stuff up and
running and the feedback from the
products are using that so far has been
that it's more compact than Java and
it's very little very readable so so far
looks good it seems like we hit the
sweet spot and for what people is
expecting it was quite quite impressive
i think is that you guys pretty much
started building a real community around
it so because you have package
management you have people contributing
those libraries and for
of packages you have people using it
early adopters so tell me more about the
community and how it's been used and and
and maybe with switz Google's interest
in all this and it's google even using
dart or planning to use it of course
they're using that so we are not doing
this is not a toy project we're doing it
for wheel and we lose about making it a
good platform for writing a scalar
scalable web applications one thing you
have to bear in mind before we have that
you would find the big web projects that
are using javascript plus comments where
the types were put in comments and your
based on these comments try to figure
out how the program was stitched
together and we're just taking the extra
step in making a language that supports
that so far for applications that are
lots and the way you have several teams
work on the same code base this is a
huge step forward and of course you know
that Google is having a lot of big web
apps and we are serious about making
sure that we have maintained these web
apps over time so yes you will in the
future see applications written in dart
from google so paralyzed from the
outside which is important so there's at
least one that's publico publicly got
talked about and Brad green from the
angular team was was up on stage
something about how they build an
application with was it a tab a team of
10 12 developers in less than six months
and none of them actually knew neither
angular nor nor dark so this is the
interesting part we have been very
conservative in designing the
programming language so that if you had
a background in the program language
like C sharp or a Java and you could
easily transition into using that
without having any surprises so our our
one of one our core goals in the sign of
the program languages there's no
surprises when using it we would like to
have each construct in the language be
so natural to understand as possible so
no matting magic was happening to the
program
think that that is key to make sure that
people like the programming language
like returning to your point about
packages and and and community around
dart it was very nice for us to be able
to give a keynote and liked the demo
that we want to show in there was
actually based on a third party you
could say like community code built by
someone outside our team just using the
dart platform and it's an excellent set
of libraries we have out there that way
so angular is very popular tell me more
about the work you've done with the
angular team so the Angela guys decided
to make a dot version of angular and
that's a great way to write apps a
framework for writing web apps and by
the end you all the logic in the program
you just specify that so and then what
kind of benefit did they expect from
that an hour are they getting it already
well they're getting some of the same
benefits as everybody else is writing in
da drive more structure to your code
it's easier to document you're intending
sort of built for writing larger
maintainable apps and you certainly get
that even in in a setting where where
you're using angular angles art and so
there's really no difference between
dart and angular dart in that in that
space angular it solves the problem of
that data binding and those things in
the angular way you could say and then
dard takes care of making sure you do
application can scale up in the in the
basic constructs that it provides so if
you if you like the nice bindings they
provide in angular and then you can use
angular Dart together with all the logic
written in that and it works just great
so yeah great so you can use dart
develop to build web apps can you use it
for command line service side is it even
makes it's a general-purpose language so
you should yes it's a deal and a
general-purpose programming language and
we always have applications that are
written outside the browser yeah yeah
the done once one should mention that
dart to J's a command-line tool it's a
compiler that takes dart code and
producers davis cup of course is written
that and of course it can compile itself
of course oh yeah so you can compile the
dart to J's compiler from dart to J's
and run on top of a javascript engine
good if you like that if you're
interested that sort of thing so that's
probably beyond the point but this is
one example where we have scaled sort of
tattoo run outside the browser so that
works really well another one is that we
have a performance tracking the server
system inside to track our increase in
performance the server side is all
written in Dart and that's been running
a stable for one and a half years now so
it even works outside the browser it
does and that's more to come here but I
think it's important to focus on web
applications now this is the first area
where we're trying to have consistent
libraries and so forth yes and when that
all works well we will be happy to
expand focus on that let's do that
really well um so you guys have had a
lot of experience in virtual machines
hotspot da where were the challenges
with dart VM specifically and it's sort
of designed to be less challenging you
can say that many of the other things
that we know right from ground up how
VMs work so that helps when you design
the language that you're trying to avoid
some of the pitfalls that make it really
hard to implement so we tried to make it
a sign that allows us to make it go
really really fast so you could say
they're honoring we designed it to make
it easier for the vm implementer so so
one thing that's we have been bothered
by in other systems is that it's very
hard to predict performance of an
application so the dart program legs has
been designed so that we can predict how
well it performs on the vm so the
programmer when writing a program he
sort of have a higgins sort of estimate
how fast it runs and this is great so
it's basically all about avoiding like
performing if it falls like if you if
you fall off that performing cliff in
too many weird ways it makes it really
hard to reason about the performance of
your code so for instance to give a
contrast to make a more concrete indira
script right you know you can use an
object as a
as a dictionary basically and if you
from the side get hold of an object
inside an application and start messing
with it suddenly the whole application
runs slow and that cannot happen in the
indata so we designed in such a way
that's not possible and I think that
that would be great for developers
because they they can they can predict
how well the code runs and should not
try to sort of guessed it whether it
once fast in one play on when plot fam
or the other so this is good so
performance by the way is not just the
app runs fast it's also about the a pro
starting fast you know in the web that
actually makes a lot of sense so this
work I understand or around that in the
dart VM terms of fast startup yeah we
have we have snapshot snapshot so
snapshot is a simple mechanism where you
basically start up the program until
you're about to execute main and that
point you take the whole heap and say I
said and put into a binary format on the
file system and you can use that as a
starting point when you start the
application and it's really you get a
factor of ten spot a start-up in
start-up performance that means that if
your application would take sort of a
second to start up now is only hundred
milliseconds and as soon as the dart VM
appears in chrome yeah then really then
you'll hopefully see a very snappy
startup of web applications already now
we're using these snapshots when
starting up dart to J's to make sure you
the tools are have a fast start up in
our toolbox yeah great so when can we
are you starting to talk to the chrome
guys to get it in of course you have a
chromium build with the document which
is what you mentioned for the
development cycle next step is obviously
to make it available as many to many
people as possible and people just
realize that the app is running faster
rate precisely as though there's the
other thing about the dart VM inside the
browser has an accelerator right so it's
not there i will take the pick up the
dose question talking to this is the
chrome bezel we are the chrome guys you
know working in the chrome team so of
course well i'm sure you need to do some
convincing before it happens the
technology speaks for itself it does
sound wonderful well on that note
congratulations again to that one that i
release where should people go to try it
out that length a talk try it out send
us a feedback there you go for you for
you guys so hopefully you like it and
send us feedback so we can improve our
system that's it yeah thank you guys
thank you